et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
yannick mireur politologue et sa liste
des états unis bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france depuis
la mort de georges floyd en mai dernier
tué par un policier blanc les
manifestations se multiplient aux etats
unis pour dénoncer les violences
policières
aujourd'hui on as on assiste à des
violences entre manifestants d'un côté
les protestataires du mouvement black
l'animateur de l'autre lé soutien aux
policiers dont faisait donc partie le
jeune homme de 17 ans auteur présumé des
tirs qui ont tué deux personnes à cannes
au chat est ce que les états unis sont
en proie aujourd'hui un risque d'émeutes
raciales selon vous elles ont déjà eu
lieu ils ont déjà eu lieu depuis
l'affairé floyd il y a déjà quelques
mois et c'est un sujet qui s'impose en
équipe concurrents si je puis dire
la question qui reste quand même
centrale celle de la pandémie et de ses
conséquences sur l'économie américaine
avec plus de 10% de chômeurs déjà je
vous le rappelle d'une certaine façon
évidemment c'est un problème d'une part
qui touche à des sujets de fond de la
société américaine on a déjà beaucoup
dit et chaque accident on va dire dans
les interventions policières ajoute de
l'huile au feu
mais du point de vue électoral puisque
on approche de l'élection présidentielle
il est bien il est bien évident que un
recul de l'économie est souvent assez
peu favorables au président en place
même si les républicains je vous
rappelle qu'il y a plus de 20 ans
maintenant le président bush père avait
perdu l'élection
malgré un bilan globalement positif pour
des questions essentiellement
économiques on va t'apporter la
présidence aux démocrates à l'époque
puisqu'il donne donc le risque de perdre
l'élection sur le recul de l'économie du
fait de la pandémie est très important
les sondages le montrent mais du point
de vue de monsieur tron qui en plus à
l'art 2
utiliser ce genre de situation d'un
point de vue politique et électoral il
est assez bien placé là dessus et bien
évidemment tout est très tentant pour
utiliser sur un discours deux ordres
eloi laurent de le situation assez
dramatique vit le pays et de dénoncer
d'autant plus des villes dans lesquelles
[Musique]
les maîtres ont lieu lorsque seront
dirigés par des démocrates ce qui est le
cas par exemple dans le whisky n'sync
mais aussi à portland on l'a vu il ya
quelques semaines
donc c'est là une opportunité quand même
pour lui de tracer une ligne rouge
suisse pu dire entre la responsabilité
et l'irresponsabilité qu'ils dénoncent
des démocrates et de la gauche à ne pas
condamner fermement la violation de la
loi par ces manifestations violentes
lorsqu'elles le sont alors justement
donald trump qui a annoncé l'envoi de
renforts policiers de soldats de la
garde nationale un hacker de chat pour
rétablir l'ordre vous l'avez rappelé est
l'un des thèmes de sa campagne de
réélection
son adversaire démocrate joe biden à lui
fait savoir qu'il avait premier justice
à la famine de jacob blake est ce que
vous direz que la campagne électorale
pour la présidence américaine attisent
aussi à les tensions certainement lé
temps elle est un vecteur le tour de
l'église particulièrement lorsqu il y à
un combat si je veux dire face à face
entre républicains et démocrates dans un
climat polarisée et il l'est depuis 20
ans le seul set
malheureusement cette détérioration du
climat
ce recul d'une sorte d' esprit de
consensus au parlement en congrès en
l'occurrence aux états unis ne date pas
de la présidence femme une certaine
manière d'ailleurs il est plus un
symptôme au fond qu'une cause de la
polarisation dans la société américaine
mais dans la situation d extrême que
nous vivons encore une fois la pandémie
la question sanitaire les questions
économiques et là dessus se greffe une
région
gensse très violence des questions
raciales et de l'intégration raciale et
sociale et économique dans la société
américaine
alors évidemment que le sujet atik les
tensions c'est bien le rôle des
démocrates de rétablir un discours et
continue du profil de monsieur maiden de
rétablir un disque ou plus traditionnels
américains et de consensus et d'unité
c'est ce qu'il s'efforce de faire il
s'efforce de le faire d'autant plus que
ces émeutes dont vous parlez tente
inquiétait beaucoup la population et
peut-être même dans des commandes
directes les circonscriptions des
arrondissements plutôt démocrate tendre
est peut-être à alarmer la population et
à la renvoyer du côté des républicains
active du new york times c'est un 10
jours qui prévenait en quelque sorte et
démocrates sur le fait de l'ordi réagi
c'est parce que les événements sont si
graves que peut-être vous pourriez en
pâtir vous même électoralement alors que
normalement quand même tous les sondages
l'indiquent cette élection vous devriez
il a remporté donc rien n'est gagné
et quand vous le dit effectivement le
fait qu'il y ait un grand des rendez
vous électoral après quatre année très
particulière que l'on vienne vivre sous
monsieur trump attise les divisions et
la polarisation et la simplification et
entre l'hystérisation tout dernier mot
si vous le voulez bien la faire jacques
love jack up blake déclencha un
boycottage sans précédent parlant du
sport équipe de baseball football
tournoi de tennis de cincinnati aussi
c'est inédit dans le sport professionnel
américain sam est un qu'anecdotique
non ce n'est pas anecdotique parce que
je pense que ça prend une ampleur et
nous une constance qui est nouvelle
rappelez-vous les anicroches entre
monsieur trump un certain nombre de
joueurs de football américain qui avait
émis genou
c'est protesté déjà et les insultes qui
avaient fusé et aussi la compréhension
qui avait dominé ces événements il se
répète ce n'est pas la première fois
ça continue de l'être je pense que ça
dénonce simplement la gravité et
l'immédiateté l'urgence de la question
raciale aux états unis
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a pas
dit grand chose parce que il y a eu
d'élection spectaculaire de monsieur
obama
il y a maintenant 12 ans ça a changé
énormément de choses parce que ce n'est
pas par décret que l'on change tout les
plus de deux siècles de passe et qui
construisent au fond explique les
disparités sociales et économiques et
les caractéristiques les spécificités
sociales économique qui perdure malgré
l'émergence d'une classe moyenne noire
il ya une classe supérieure aux états
unis depuis en particulier des dernières
vous dire demi siècle qui perdure dans
la société américaine et ça prend
beaucoup de temps
il est certain en revanche que on a le
sentiment
ce n'est pas nécessairement la vérité on
a le sentiment que avec ces violences
urbaines
la tendance vers le progrès il on nous
amène un recul
bon je pense que derrière le
spectaculaire il faut voir les tendances
de fond et l'amélioration considérable
qu'il y a eu pour la condition d'une
bonne partie de la population noire aux
etats-unis il y avait là la
l'affirmative action je vous rappelle
dans les universités soit 170 sur
laquelle on est revenus d'ailleurs parce
que les résultats ne sont pas si
extraordinaire ce que l'on pouvait
escompter
bref il ya eu énormément de choses qui
ont été faites et beaucoup
d'améliorations mais ça n'est pas ni par
décret ni dans l'espace d'une génération
même d'une génération et demi que ces
problèmes très anciens très profonde
états unis vont être résolus
malheureusement merci beaucoup yannick
mireur je rappelle que vous êtes le
politologue spécialiste des états unis